happy Thanksgiving week everybody that
means less time at work more time
avoiding your family and watching
football Chris Sims how are you good how
are you I am getting ready as soon as we
get done this podcast I'm rushing to JFK
Airport on a plane to go to Vegas we
have confirmed I am getting satellite
television on the plane which is an
incredible invention sure sure you are
to watch Kansas City the RAM sure you
are until you get on the plane and they
tell you it's not working right so I
just start clicking and it's like ESPN
is not available yes that's happened
before I know I don't know what I would
do be okay I'm telling you I would I
would put myself in the overhead
container and I would suck my thumb for
five hours I'm asleep that would be good
good footage what Chiefs Rams obviously
the game of the year is gonna be Monday
night were recording this Monday
afternoon wild Sunday slate same as
meanwhile on Saturday you looked like an
18th century war lieutenant at Yankee
Stadium yeah KITT man it's beautiful
that's the look I was going for I love
it you know when you want to bring back
the history of the New York Yankees
that's what you do you try to look like
you're a history major yeah that was fun
that was really cool to be a part of it
really what is it you know notre dame
play notre dame yeah I mean Notre Dame
is such a following up in here in the
New York area
you said random people stop you on the
street and just talk to you about Notre
Dame they do all the time it's such an
amazing how it's just this little cult
of a fan base but you know between that
and then of course your school your alma
mater had a great that a great showing
there I still think it was 80/20 Notre
Dame fans of Syracuse but Notre Dame
controlled 90% of the tickets so that's
the reason they had of course the big
swing there but Notre Dame's really good
I don't know it's really weird they're
my whole life I've been telling people
they're overrated they're overrated and
then this year they're actually and I'm
working for them this year and a part of
the telecast and all that and no they're
they're really talented I I honestly
could sit here and go I think they're
the second best team in college football
we know who number one is yeah but I
mean Clemson would have their hands full
playing Notre Dame
mm-hmm yes without doubt look college
football talk yeah everybody's got NFL
players all over the field that they do
they do I want to check in really
quickly on our Super Bowl prediction
okay see how they're doing so let me go
to NFL Jesus really quick I just don't
see the standings but I think we'll know
how your NFC team is doing seems a Super
Bowl picks before the year Saints
Steelers mmm really both teams have a
bye in the playoffs right now how does
that feel it feels good uh Pittsburgh is
currently the two seed one game ahead of
New England and Houston and the Chargers
in the lost column I did not realize yes
that there are three teams the AFC that
are seven and three yeah Pittsburgh
seven two and one and then Kansas City's
starting to pull away at nine and one
we'll see what happens right yeah
Houston New England and the Chargers all
at 7:30 right then Pittsburgh's at 7:00
two and one so you get your team as the
bye right yeah you feel confident about
both of those if you could switch one
would you I definitely wouldn't switch
the Saints and no I feel really good
about it I think it'll go with the steel
I do
I think the Steelers I don't look at
them and go they're worse than the
Chiefs are worse than the Patriots I
think they're every bit matchup for them
there's the year for them to beat New
England I do think this is the year they
can do it but you were saying earlier
the Patriots have not won a road playoff
game since oh six since the Brady threw
the interception to the chargers Antoine
Kayson had an interception that bumbled
so your told me I was a fluke 12 years
ago I said last time is the last time
game yeah the last time I saw Brady play
a road playoff game he was getting
destroyed by the Denver Broncos defense
yes right mm and we were like is it over
right and but they haven't been on there
you know it's a sounds like a more
jolting stat than it really is well they
haven't won a road playoff game in 12
years right
I mean what is that three three games
we're talking about to Denver AFC
championships and then the the week
after that Chargers game they had to go
to the Colts and play there and got the
twenty to six lead at halftime and
that's what paint oh my god okay right
right my Super Bowl picks yeah
Texans Packers okay
the fact that Texans are here this is
right where I thought they'd be yeah
remember I thought the Texans would have
a miracle win in New England that would
send them to the Super Bowl Packers I
don't know if they're even gonna get to
the playoffs for five and one currently
in the nine spot but they're battling it
out with Carolina and Minnesota
I mean they could make it look the sixth
seed in the AFC is wide open and the
sixth seed and the five seed in the NFC
I think it's still wide open yes and can
Green Bay according to NBC stat last
night has the easiest schedule remaining
the rest of the right no III don't I
don't think anything's done there as far
as that discussion Minnesota still got a
play Green Bay one more time
I mean Minnesota's got to play the Bears
one more time Green Bay goes to
Minnesota home against the Cardinals
home against the Falcons at Chicago at
the Jets home against the Lions Wow
they can make a run they definitely can
make it run I mean they have a few
things that I don't feel confident that
either of my teams if I could switch it
up right now I would go to I probably go
to Saints Chiefs Saints Chiefs but then
if I was like Adam be smart I'd pick
Saint Saens Patriots right which would
either way would be great Super Bowls I
think I mentioned the ramps well yeah I
mean I'm taking the same so with the
Rams it's a close one but of the Rams I
still think I look at and maybe I'm
swayed by we're taping this on a Monday
yeah we don't know what's gonna I don't
know but I think right now I still think
that the Saints and Rams are the two
best teams in football for me we're all
yeah I would put them above the Chiefs
still I mean tonight will be the final
so you'd go Saint Rams Chiefs yeah then
probably Pittsburgh I'd probably go New
England then Pittsburgh just because I'm
not gonna be swayed by New England you
know playing a horrible game in
Tennessee against a coach that's very
familiar Shaq Mason being out Sony
Michelle not quite being there Gronk was
in there trying left halfway through the
game so before we all go on it's
November right and we'll see the
Patriots ingenuine exactly right so yes
I would probably put them a little bit
over Pittsburgh do you have any idea
what has happened with us and the Saints
fans in the last 72 hours I'm
hoping do you realize that we've been
public enemy number one and for the last
72 hours
really so bleacher report released the
clip in the middle of our show in which
I said that Drew Brees throws 40% of us
passes our screens and dump offs and
that we said that the the MVP trophy is
not a Lifetime Achievement Award that's
right we have been getting eviscerated
by Saints fans even though you picked
them to go to the Super Bowl right we
have been getting a visser ated this is
something that honestly Josh and I have
been trying to avoid for a very long
time but it went out and it sucks
because did I was I really saying that
40 percent of the time I was just kind
of saying yeah but destroyed that entire
game Kristen people are doing podcasts
are doing videos going Sims and left go
please come down in New Orleans I want
to punch you in the face one guy wanted
to see me go to jail everyone's asking
for us to be fired man I thought
yesterday even accentuated it even more
what do you mean I mean just about the
drew brees MVP thing how easy it was I
mean the games just done a silver
platter here's funny because everybody
was run for ten and run for 12 and run
for 20 everybody was saying there's no
screens here these are all deep passes
yeah they had a few certainly and you
know I'll give you a better breakdown
when I get to watch the film of the game
but uh again we're not sitting here just
trying to say drew Brees is horrible or
anything like that we were just saying
again I think the big conversation the
point we have tried to make is that
Kansas City has become special because
of Patrick mahomes the Rams are special
on offense cuz of Todd Gurley the Saints
are special on offense but I can't just
sit here and go because it's drew Brees
there's a lot of things that play into
it he's certainly an important part but
when you talk about the best offensive
line in the sport and arguably the best
running back duo in the sport okay and
yes there's and they're gonna say but
they threw touchdowns to all these low
name guys yesterday like Austin Carville
I never heard of then I would go the
Eagles came in with an awful secondary
already do you knew who was playing
corner with us in the secondary
yesterday with
Jenkins let me read you these names yeah
Rasul Douglas Craven LeBlanc I've never
heard of him
he was with the Bears Chandon Sullivan
right never heard of him Devante boss P
move I've never heard of him
Trey Sullivan I just look I I tweeted
out after the game
lesson learned you talk a little [ __ ]
about Drew Brees and he bends you over
his knee and makes you his fifth kid
sure it's been retweeted over 300 times
and liked 1,300 times and I had a lot of
people saying I don't care
shut the F up you're an idiot okay my
thing is this is that Drew Brees is
having an amazing year yeah and that
he's had an amazing career and he's a
top 10 quarterback of all time and he's
a future hall-of-famer and if you read
the Peter King incredible article in
football morning in America about the
relationship that he has with Sean
Payton and how incredibly in sync they
are it's special yes and we're not
doubting any of that no he's really good
he's a top-five quarterback in the NFL
right now it's he's seen he's playing at
such a high level I'm more saying what
you've always said is I don't think
people give Sean Payton their respect
right and it's you've always said you
give Sean Payton all a lot more of the
credit well yeah he's he's I mean he's
one of the greatest play designers play
callers offensive minds in the history
of the NFL so of course I do yeah there
I mean again they're tied at the hip
together and what they've done together
overall in the offensive side of the
ball is magical you know again and and
Drew Brees he deserves to be in the
conversation for the MVP and maybe he
goes on fire here at the end of the year
and if he does and continues to play
awesome then I will sit here ago he is
the MVP I don't have any issue with that
but I'm not gonna just give you the MVP
because you're the most notable guy I'm
the best team in the league and because
this might be your last chance to win
the MVP that's know I'm gonna play that
I would like to play this too you know
again Drew Brees is the only quarterback
out of the major quarterbacks that gets
a free pass for going to the playoffs
like twice out of the last eight years
everybody else they're an issue when
that happens I mean if Aaron Rodgers
win the Super Bowl he's a disgrace but
drew brees goes to the playoffs twice
since 2011 and that's okay because why
oh because his defense wasn't good but
some other defenses for other
quarterbacks that didn't have that same
thing that doesn't matter for them so
that's my issue currently has a
quarterback rating of 120 6.9 he's
throwing 25 touchdowns one interception
yeah and he's got 2,900 passing yards 29
60 or so a lot of people would say no
he's playing it at his best season in
his entire career he's had a Hall of
Fame girl yeah I did why cuz of the
stats say that no I would already argue
there's been years that have been better
than that I don't care about the bottom
line stat number that does not say
you're having your best year of your
career you know just that's a different
conversation to me but that's the
conversation we're stuck in and
quarterback world right now quarterback
does everything that said we all have to
get out of this mold that people would
also bring up the fact that he threw a
few passes to a man named Kirkwood he
threw passes to a man named Arnold to
Austin Carr and he was able to perform
with those and not relying on just the
Michael Thomas's in the Alvin Kamara
yeah ok great I mean I don't what do you
want me to say that's he did just
bringing up counterpoints yeah no I know
I mean he did that's that's great again
it's the offense to nobody again you
could see the attention nobody
double-teams Michael Thomas right
the Eagles did double-team like maybe a
few times ok by the way Sean Payton said
this after the game right I've never
seen the Eagles placed so much
man-to-man yeah this is a question about
the Eagles I'm changing topics ok quick
good and we're gonna get back to Jerry's
but I just read you those names yeah
crow Vaughn LeBlanc right Devante boss P
yeah and you decide to play that much
man-to-man with those guys yeah nice Jim
Schwartz doing well it's he's being
aggressive but I think more times and
not as probably has something to do with
worrying about the run game that's what
he's worried about loading the box and
trying to stop everything they do inside
again I got to watch the film of that
game before I can answer some of those
questions I haven't been able to do that
but these ways the Saints can attack you
they're infinite I mean it never ends
you know they're just so
amazing it not only the drop back pass
game the run game is you know multiple
you got to taste some he'll thing added
to the fact that it's already one of the
best run games there are then you go oh
they're screen game as arguably as good
or better than anybody in football too
so it's all the different ways they can
attack you that you know just kill
Philadelphia and of course
Philadelphia's greatest strength is your
defensive front and that gets negated
against a team like the Saints who can
handle anybody's defensive front mmm
yeah I I the fact that you've
experienced none of this Saints vitriol
and my phone is just blowing up yeah
it's ridiculous i I mean that's why I'm
gonna be on social media I just you know
again I don't care statistics came out
after a video went out saying that Drew
Brees throws a ton less of a like a very
small amount of his yardage compared to
Patrick mahomes as on screens yeah yeah
you know maybe that's right
I don't know again is a difference in
the about how they go about getting
their your explain that yeah I mean
Patrick mahomes teams are playing that
sucked about that video is all the
nuance about our discussion was taken
away yeah so explain what you mean by
well Patrick mahomes and what he brings
to the Kansas City Chiefs offense is his
talent makes everything easier again you
know the point we need to make is Alec
Smith was number one rated quarterback
in that offense last year he threw 25
touchdown passes here's Patrick mahomes
little past halfway point
he's got 31 and we haven't even seen him
play against the Rams later tonight so
to me there again is showing you how
much greater he is and his abilities and
what they do as far as opening up an
offense because of his big arm because
and Erie can call plays that really you
can't even call with except for a
Patrick of Holmes or maybe three or four
other quarterbacks in the sport then
defenses have to go man we got to worry
about this guy we'll throw a 50-yard
missile right by our defenders to Tyree
killer Sammy Watkins so then they play
for that then the shallow cross there's
wide open and we go oh look he gets easy
completions too you know he gets easy
completions because everybody's scared
of his physical talent where I would say
more times you're not Drew Brees gets
easy completions because
the offense is designed at such a high
level and they can beat you in so many
different ways that's where it's
different and the nuance does matter
again Drew Brees can make all the big
throws I'm not denying that we know he
can but teams aren't going oh gosh we
got to really tell our defense to get
back this week and we can't even play
this coverage against this quarterback
or he will torch us you know it's just a
different setting there and about the
attack of the offense overall is is
different and I mean you know hey this
green thing might be right
it doesn't matter I just you know the
thing you need to look at is just all
the people that are wide open in the
Saints game more than anything you know
and I'll be able to give you more of
these real answers to what happened
particularly this week but I know
because I watch them on offense every
week of what they do I'm not trying to
be a hater
I'm telling you it's the greatest
offensive attack in the sport right now
and they can do it any which way they
want mmm Peter King in his article the
some we've talked about a lot apparently
Peter King went to Sean Payton and was
like man I just saw Tyree kill and Sean
Payton apparently in this article said
hey drew tell Peter is the most
dangerous player in football right now
and Brees said Tyree kill and Peyton
beamed and nodded so even that team goes
man Tyree kill is the most dangerous
player in the sport yeah as in receiver
or anything else do you want to call him
I and I I got a knock on Patrick mahomes
as MVP standing if he's got the most
dangerous player is that why the Saints
talked about it I I mean I don't know if
it's a knock on it you know what they
can call whatever they want he became a
lot more dangerous with Patrick mahomes
at quarterback I know that we're in the
conversation we're talking about him
this year and that guy and that way and
we weren't last year I guess you're you
were trying to say this and nobody could
believe you because they couldn't get
the ball to exactly right last year I'd
come away gone damn they missed like
four shots down the field for a hundred
and eighty yards of tyree kill and Alex
wouldn't throw him the football you know
this year it's the exact opposite
I mean Tyreke Hill becomes a decoy more
time more times than not because because
of the attention that he Garner's from
the defense and then mahomes his ability
to throw and then that's where the
Kelsey underneath and Kareem hunt
underneath and all that come about I
mean I'm sick of talking about this
subject
how come it's just it's just I mean I
think drew brees is awesome I think
their offense is awesome I think the
other two guys in front of them in the
MVP race are more valuable to their team
than he is kirlyam Mahone yeah you
believe that if the Saints lost Drew
Brees they'd be ok or they'd be better
more better off than the Rams if they
lost Gurley and the chief said they lost
mahomes yes you think Taysom Hill or
Teddy Bridgewater can go in there and
they can still win some games
I definitely whereas if the Chiefs had
to put in their backup quarterback or
the Corps the Rams had to stick with
Malcolm Brown not so much no that's it's
over it's over where I would go man make
you know Saints Teddy Bridgewater they
could still make go to the Superbowl
like that's that's where I would say you
believe the Saints can still go the
Superbowl with Teddy Bridgewater I do
yes yeah I know it's gonna sound like
it's a knock on your breeze it's not the
Giants went to the Super Bowl with Jeff
Hostetler my dad was still Sims ok
Carson Wentz was the MVP of football
last year he got hurt the Eagles still
went to the Super Bowl you know stop
making it about one guy everybody stop
it's just but you're making it about one
guy with mahomes and girly I'm not I'm
saying as far as their offensive design
and the way their games package I'm just
saying you can't give all the success to
just one guy all the time we're this
quarterback environment where we just go
quarterback quarterback quarterback
there needs to be some help around you
it's not just about one guy in any
situation only guy would argue again the
COS could do that as number 12 in Green
Bay again you know and people are gonna
go oh well I don't you know I want to
say like okay we never knew who James
Jones was until he played for the Green
Bay Packers and then when he left
Georgetown he couldn't even do anything
he couldn't make the Giants he couldn't
make the Raiders then they said they
went back to the new Green Bay he led
the league in touchdowns again so you
know but I don't even know what I'm
getting into this conversation he's
really awesome I get that and their
offense is awesome and their awesome
team and I think they're gonna win the
Super Bowl I will say that when the
Saints play every single yard and play
is though all Drew Brees audibled that
Oh drew Brees saw that and I I just
don't think people understand how great
Sean Payton is and we we talk about this
all the time I know okay I honestly want
to sit here and go over the playlist of
the game I want to see the plays you
talk about him being double-teamed I
mean I
i watch the games other games going on I
mean I don't know if I've ever seen
Michael Thomas double team this year
please let me know because Peter King
wrote about and I don't think Peters are
exaggerating but I mean either way
Michael Thomas is awesome - I know I
take a lot of crap for that but whatever
all right so your other Super Bowl teen
the Steelers yeah they come back and get
the wind down 16 nothing and Jalen
Ramsey after rumors that he could get
traded which the Jaguars denied first of
all there's a few Sunday dumps that were
ridiculous but how does that come out
and then the team denies it I really
don't know I don't even know what to say
there I mean who reported that that was
that was a possibility there were two
huge stories yesterday that got reported
and then retracted that in the
Condoleezza Rice story yeah because the
Condoleezza Rice he didn't even like say
it I think when you read the context
interested in interview yeah it's right
so that's again I don't know what else
to say that was shefter yeah yeah yeah
it's just it was shefter they denied it
and with Jalen Ramsey - you're saying
that's why I'm saying that one yeah they
both both of his stories got tonight I
just don't think shefter someone that's
gonna float things no I mean I don't
know where he gets that either way
they're crazy if they want to trade
Jalen Ramsey he was phenomenal in that
game yesterday and I hear people I heard
some of that this morning - Oh Jalen
Ramsey he didn't play good what are you
kidding his two interceptions were in
court he lived on an island with a B and
JooJoo Smith Schuster yeah they made a
few catches did you see how awesome that
throw was at the end of the game I mean
that was that's almost impossible to
defend that was the same play that
Antonio Brown and them ran what the
little I mean the little slant over the
middle Carolina it was the Carolina
Panthers you went up the sideline no I'm
talking about the one over the middle
that Antonio Brown had for a touchdown
earlier this year was that I guess the
Baltimore Ravens I can't remember but
it's like a pic play slant I mean but
they're just going there forget the pic
Jalen cover Antonio Brown we don't care
he was all over it was an amazing throw
I felt really bad for the Jaguars
defense yeah I mean the offense I was
putting down on my place sheet here as
I'm watching the game one drive they ran
13 times in a row and I'm gonna be
honest I listened to a lot of shows on
Monday morning just to kind of see what
other people are talking about I listen
to two podcasts I read a few articles
and I'm seeing everyone talking about
how the Jaguars are playing like it's
the 1940s they're running too much we're
in a throw throw league do you think the
Jaguars don't want to throw you think
that they're looking around the league
in Nathaniel hack it's like you know
what I'm gonna run it 41 times because I
hate running I hate throwing the ball
that's not the case everytime bortles
dropped back to throw at those 16 times
you're holding your breath the they are
not they do not want to play like this
they're playing like this because they
this is not their decision they made a
decision last year that's causing them
to play like this which was giving Blake
bortles that extension when nobody else
is gonna give him the money
yeah and so I feel like they're doing
this because they have to do this with
Blake bortles Doug Marrone has come out
today and say they're not going to bench
Blake bortles for next weekend for
Buffalo but they're doing this because
they have to not because they want to no
way it'll stink this is the this is
again this is where they've backed
themselves into this corner you know
with the fact that they drafted him at
number three would the fact that you
know he gave them false confidence why
because he threw a few balls that were
nice when they were up 28 to 7 and there
was no pressure in the game against the
Steelers or you know hey threw a nice a
few nice completions against the
Patriots who were like the 28th rate of
defense in football last year you know
again taking none of that away but yeah
it's just this is the situation they're
in of course they don't want to play
this way as you see with any game that
he struggles as soon as the back out of
the backfield is taken away and the
shallow cross is taken away the game
gets very interesting note was the
leading receiver on the team there you
know we talked about it last week he had
26 completions against the Colts I think
only like two or three were like
legitimate downfield throws everything
else was a screen a boot or a shallow
cross and you're seeing that the good
defenses have finally figured that out
like oh these are the three areas they
throw to there's an occasional something
else in there but for the most part
that's where he is comfortable throwing
and that's where they make their game
plan designed to throw it because they
know he's incapable of making some other
throws AJ Bowie a being back seemed to
have a huge impact why do the Jaguars
matter
shut what the stealer so long I think
because they can play man-to-man at
times I think they can stop their run
game because the Steelers are a little
bit of a zone run team and there they
are a zone run team and I think the dis
the movement that the jaguars do up
front kind of makes it hard to block a
zone when guys are slanting and looping
and twisting around I think that makes
it hard you know the the Steelers are a
team that kind of goes into a game going
we're gonna be the physical fast team
out here and the jaguars matchup from
that capacity but you know at the end of
the game yeah there was there was one
team that had a quarterback that was oh
okay we're down 16-0 oh you blew a
coverage well there's Antonio Brown for
a 70 something yard touchdown pass kind
of got them into the swing of the
football game and they found out you
know just a few wooden few ways to get
people open down the field two of the
final four teams Eagles Jaguars are they
both done yes I think so too yeah I do
too I mean your injuries in your team
finish you I don't even care about your
stats I was gonna say is they with
Washington twice the Giants in Dallas
the good thing is is none of those teams
are really throwing teams yeah all the
team's their own division but they're
gonna get a few plays on that awful
secondary Houston can absolutely do some
stuff to that secondary I just the pass
rush hasn't been as incredible as it
needs to be to overcome how injured the
secondary is that's right and in Carson
Wentz right now he's just not got a lot
of time I mean Jason Kelsey goes down
the first drive the offensive line
hasn't been that good isaacsohn melo has
been having a good year and Golden Tate
looks like a non-factor this it all
plays together I mean yeah the defensive
guys you lost the big thing for me with
the Eagles is just the run game you do
not have a run game in New York and it's
all about Carson dropping back to the
hallways stolen for 77% yeah great I
mean the balls going nowhere I mean you
know it's just it's it's too many long
drives it's too much work every series
for for your Eagles offense and yeah
there's there's lack of creativity on
the offensive side of the ball too
there's too many repeat concepts there's
just not enough you know anything
creative on that side of the ball to
open up people down the field or
whatever it may be all that's an
endearing
yes it's all an indie indie we've
learned over the last few weeks that
Frank Reich was certainly a huge
architect in that offense as far as game
plan plays on a weekly basis I see
everybody talking about John Dee Filippo
I mean I don't know I'm watching
Minnesota Chicago and their concepts
look super simple and I'm watching the
Eagles and their concepts look super
simple and micro really isn't doing that
much with the Eagles but every time I
turn on the Colts incredible motion
great formations good protection good
rhymey I think they ran for over 200
yards against the Titans did I know
we're gonna get to them in a second okay
let me go to my my Super Bowl Tina I
think still has a chance right
Texans Washington you had 750 dollars of
your bleacher bucks on the Texans -
three yeah Alex Smith breaks his leg and
Colt McCoy comes in and they still
didn't cover yeah III was not like
necessarily happy about that
what do you mean I knew Colt McCoy was
gonna come in and be aggressive you know
that they're not gonna miss a beat with
Colt McCoy a quarterback not a beat like
not a beat I would argue that he is
every bit as good if not better than
Alex Smith better athlete Alex Smith
just got better that's their fault I
don't know what to tell them they they
because it's all about the quarterback
propaganda in this league right now
that's all it's about oh we got our guy
I've got our franchise guy now you guys
will believe in us now right oh okay
yeah are you truly in your heart yes
believe that Colt McCoy could be better
than Alex Smith I do yeah yeah I mean
Cole McCoy's everybody's gonna a seat
he's ingress more aggressive decision
maker it's not gonna be easy going into
Dallas this week not with that team
their offense is banged up - yeah so it
might not look pretty but no he complied
the position every business Kobuk we
deserved a chance to be a starter at
some point he's had success every time
he's been put in ours I know you know
and I think he really thought there was
a point where I think he felt cheated
that that Kirk Cousins kind of got to
pass him up there and he never got a
chance to compete there and I think he
was upset this year that they didn't let
him go and be the guy this year because
I know there was some talk after they
franchise Kirk Cousins the second time
you know right before that they were
going well maybe we should just let her
go would just make Colt the guy I mean
that wasn't talked about was a
definitely conversation within the
reservation cold I am he's one of the
best backups in football I mean he came
in and like first play was like a 15
yard run yeah side right I know that and
then he threw the touchdown pass in the
corner pass on the corner route um you
know either way getting back to the game
you know the Texans
I think we're clearly the better team on
the football field the Texans are scary
just because they can be inconsistent
they can make mistakes you know you know
they're a little over aggressive on
defense you saw a few jumping offsides
type of things like that and some bad
moments you know deshaun Watson turning
the ball over throwing some stupid
interceptions they had the unfortunate
DeAndre Hopkins ball down the middle
where he caught and bobbled it you had
deshaun Watson fumbles he was getting
sacked backed up right after Alex Smith
broke his leg and you go oh god here
goes the Texans they're gonna control
the game I still like the way the Texans
play they're a phenomenal football team
they just they like playing in close
games I just I can't believe you said
about I like Smith & Co McCoy but I love
it I thought there was one guy that
Washington should during the twelve or
twenty seven and two interceptions does
that make you question that there's one
guy that I think Washington could trade
for but they'd never do it and it's a
guy that even though we saw Lamar
Jackson looking incredible there's a guy
behind him that I think it's a wasted
rg3 year there's a zero percent chance
that Washington would trade for rg3 zero
but I feel like that would be the guy to
go to but it sounds like you're
confident in Colt so not I'm gonna bring
it yeah don't
I mean cold as cold as legit he really
is he's one of the best backup
quarterbacks in the sport never gets
talked about no he does not
Houston where's your level of confidence
in them as a 7 & 3 team having won seven
in a row I really like Houston I still
do I still think they need some more
offensive creativity but how do you not
like what they do on defense you know
just as Sean makes some questionable
decisions yeah this Sean was a little
question but they do think there are
another offense I'd look at and I just
gotta go up make things a little easier
on DeSean I think we wrote like I wrote
in my notes last week they got a
and some shorter bullcrap schemes that
we you know talked about that the
Patriots have sometimes some of the
underneath Edelman and mandola type rats
and almond Amidala's out there but that
kind of stuff well it does not exist as
much in the Houston offense it's always
about the Shawn sitting back there kind
of buying time waiting for an aggressive
throw to open up down the field and it's
not it's buy more time and move around
and I just don't know if that's
sustainable that interception inside
that twenty and I was like oh no Texas
are gonna lose this game but yeah so
Washington do you still think Washington
is a chance to win the division who
would you put like the Cowboys yeah I
would the Washington's gonna fight
though like oh yeah that's the one thing
you got to give respect to a Jay Gruden
you know their their D coordinator
mineski like they play tough you know
they really do I mean yesterday I would
have thought there was a chance they got
their head head beaten beaten in and
they hung in that football game and I
give him credit for that I think they'll
hang in there with Dallas on Thursday
night too I do too I think 7 1/2 us wage
was a lot Packers Seahawks Thursday
night a lot of people are getting into
this is it Rogers is it McCarthy because
the problem is is there's you know
Rodgers passed up Aaron Jones a little
dumped off on third down and everybody
circled that and so this was an issue
and then third and two Rodgers the ball
freakishly stuck in his hand and he need
to make the throw and McCarthy
subsequently punted even though Mike
Daniels and Kenny Clark weren't in the
game and they just led up to 70 plus
yard drives for two scores a touchdown
on a field goal why would you take Aaron
off the field but you know how is this
is Aaron at fault for any of the Packers
offense right now yeah he missed the
throw you know one third and two or
whatever it was third and one you know
he but he hasn't been perfect but it's
very hard I mean that so we've heard all
these ex quarterbacks all these players
we've talked to they all go Aaron
Rodgers the best player they've ever
played against I haven't heard anybody
say Michael McCarthy's the best play
caller that beyond I guess nobody nobody
in the history haven't heard right so so
really we're gonna have that discussion
who again
who was having it over after this year
yeah it feels like yeah they're they're
in deep crap it is over I mean they're
gonna said josh mcdaniels III hear that
I mean that would be something that I
think would get Josh off his butt in New
England he go what okay I'll come there
and meet you guys and talk this out
let's have a conversation
hmm I mean did the chance to cat the
coach and Aaron Rodgers why he still got
some really good years in front of them
here but you know uh yeah I mean really
are people really having that
conversation I know that Aaron Rodgers
gets you know in trouble with a lot I
tweeted this out a few days ago possible
coaching movement yeah Mike McCarthy
gets fired rejoins John Dorsey in
Cleveland hmm first of all my question
would be do you think John Dorsey would
want Baker with Mike McCarthy after
we're sitting here talking about Mike
McCarthy not being good for Aaron
Rodgers yeah I I don't know that's a if
I'm bringing my shoe so do you want to
State of the Union well if I'm bringing
Mike McCarthy in as a head coach that's
fine I'm just going Mike you're not
allowed to run the offense
Yury the head coach that's what you are
but we're gonna bring in you know this
guy Joe Smith to be our offensive
coordinator because we feel like he's
more equipped to do that but your head
coaching skills your ability to manage
the game they've checked out and they're
fine I have the Browns getting Mike
McCarthy the Packers getting Josh
McDaniels the Jets getting John Harbaugh
the Ravens getting David Shaw the
Broncos getting Dave talbe special teams
coordinator for the Chiefs
I would love Elway to raid the Chiefs
and the Bucs to get Chris Rashard do I
have any you like any of those I do I do
like those yeah I do I mean I think
they're all viable candidates I don't
know about David Shaw if he's willing to
make that jump well yeah I think he
seems kind of comfy and cozy I just want
everything with the Bucs the only thing
that I would I would think about there
is like rich masaccio again just like
your Dave towel oh yeah but Sachi was
down there he's just like a Dave tab as
far as it got as a tonight for the
Raider exactly and he's just got a great
way about him he's a great leader of men
understands the total scope of the game
you know he'd be a guy I'd say to watch
out for I do think his name will come up
in conversations your searches will
you texted me after the game and said
that something's up with russell
wilson's mechanics well it's always been
that way it's just he's talented and it
doesn't always matter but you saw saw
the throws he misses early in the game
right it's double wide oh he misses
number of throws early on and you know I
thought that Joe you know Joe Buck and
Eggman did a good job of pointing it out
I mean there was even some short throws
where you go my and that's gonna be a
first down if he just puts it on the
money but you know he's one of the few
quarterbacks in all of football that
throws the football like a baseball
right it's not turn your shoulder always
it's more of a dropping of the arm and
let me throw it that way like I got a
small object around me that's fine and
dandy but it's not really the proper
mechanics of throwing a football and I
think that's why at times you see some
errant footballs come out of Russell's
hands because it is really him just
doing it with pure physical talent you
know where a guy like Rodgers his
mechanics even though they look like
they're back yardage they're flawless I
mean they're flawless they're perfect he
always can rely on them you know just
like anything how I talk about like you
might have a golfer out there who he's
got no mechanics and he goes out there
and shoots 73 days in a row but then
that fourth day he goes out there and I
just don't feel as good today and all
sudden he shoots 85 you know instead of
the guy who's got mechanics and go man I
shot 70 I shot 70 I shot 70 and that
fourth day he goes out there goes man I
don't feel really good but if I just
stick with my mechanics I'll shoot 72 I
won't fall all the way down to 85 I
don't know if that makes sense that
anybody out there but that's what
mechanics do for you on those days where
you're a little off you can always go
back to them and go okay let me keep my
front shoulder in there let me step just
right at the target
he has a different motion I mean you
know anybody out there look at
highlights of Russell Wilson how he kind
of drops the ball and throws it that way
it's more like a shortstop than it is a
quarterback
what leads to a player being off I mean
and how soon in the day do you know oh
I'm off gosh I mean sometimes for me
personally and warm up sometimes I just
go damn I don't got it today like
okay that's not gonna flip no I just I
gotta start I almost got to start back
at Route one I mean then just or square
one I should say and just start to go
back into my mechanics and go I you know
keep your front shoulder in there keep
your arm tight things like that that
kind of gets you back on track but
there's other days yeah where I go out
there and I I don't know my mechanics
are right or not I'm just going damn I
think feels good coming out of my hand
today I am throwing some piss missiles
and they are howling through the wind if
you were once like anything what makes a
day where you play basketball
yeah well makes it a day where one day
you got it the other way you don't yeah
you know what is it you're doing
fadeaways it's not even hitting the rim
yeah then the next day you go out there
and you're gonna [ __ ] I've been standing
with the crow line and I'll chew for ten
my thing for you would be if I showed
you footage of all the quarterbacks in
pregame yeah could you tell me who was
gonna be on and who wasn't just by watch
if you let me watch like yet total
pregame routes first they're throwing
the ball yeah I think more times than
not I could I've been on the field
you're looking for what can I look for
when Fox shows me 15 seconds of Stafford
yeah well it's gonna be hard for there
you need more than one throw or two
throws but the things I look for like if
I was at a game you know just the
quality of the ball coming out of the
guy's hand right off the bat its first
I'm gonna look at like oh damn he's you
know that's nine wobblers in a row like
yeah hit the target but it's not coming
out of his hand clean or the next thing
I go after that is going okay go damn
he's he's 7 for 10 against air what's he
gonna be against when the defense is out
there if he's 7 and 10 and nobody's out
there what's it gonna be like here a
little while when you know the Broncos
are flying around or something like that
it's always just little things like that
that you look for in pregame warmup you
could see it if you go to a game and you
got there early you could definitely see
certain games where you're gonna go oh
okay this guy's not striping it like
normal do the Bears have the best
defense of the NFL I think they do
pulling up the team's just to make sure
Eddie Jackson's phenomenal oh well Mack
is out of this world
Hakeem Hicks out of this world Eddie
Goldman out of this world they're
they're a combination yeah I think one
defense in football I take the
bears right with Vic Fangio yes yes with
Vic Fangio yeah Vic Fangio falls along
those lines of like the great offensive
play cars we talked about you know he's
a defensive play caller like where he
they think outside the box a little on a
weekly basis okay cover three might look
like this all training camp but cover
three this week against this team I want
you to make it look a little bit more
like this because when we Pike cover
three they like to attack this area so
we're gonna bump everybody over or
whatever it may be
games plans specific type stuff on a
weekly basis is that rare it is like the
Seattle's of the world like we talked
about they don't do that stuff the align
of Falcons they don't just said this is
what we do we're gonna line up and this
is what we're gonna play we're really
good at it and we're gonna make you
execute bears are such a team of two
halves first half I feel like they go
out there and they blow people up and
then the second half it's a combination
of coasting and the offense stops
clicking yes your level of confidence in
the Bears right now my level of
confidence with the Bears is extremely
high you know again I'm not expecting
the Bears to be the Kansas City Chiefs
so I I hope nobody else's you know that
they have weapons on their offense sure
Biscay certainly can miss a few throws
every now and then that you'd like to
see him hit or make a few dumb decisions
too like we saw last night but then the
other thing I would say to his men there
was a number of plays where we said wow
like whoa that was that was unbelievable
scrambling in the pocket making a throw
on the run or that was an unbelievable
scramble and going get 10 or 12 yards
you know so again I don't think he's
ever gonna be like perfect pocket
quarterback passer this year to where we
just think oh he could be Drew Brees and
he's gonna be surgical within the pocket
know he's developing into that still but
he still makes a number of big throws
every week a number of big runs his
talents do put pressure on a defense I
mean we heard Mike Zimmer and halftime
we're gonna have to put a spy on Mitchel
too risky yeah yeah okay yeah that's
right you got it because he's that
talented a runner
I like the Bears I don't know how do you
feel about him I think that they're a
team that can compete with anybody but I
worry about them in the second half of
really taking yeah I mean can they get
in a shootout if they have to play the
Saints to the Rams like I feel like they
don't know they have a roster when
you're cooking it feels great the
Anthony Miller's the tarik Cohen's
Jordan Howard really didn't show up last
night but he's a really good player yeah
Allen Robinson tre Burton they have all
these weapons I just I don't really see
anyone that's gonna take over a game
from a just at personnel perspective
yeah and then Mitch is just not I don't
think he's ready this year to make a run
I just I know a young team they're very
young yeah I mean they showed all the
ages yesterday and like none of their
position groups the average age is all
28 or younger and I would have defense
though I think is ready right the
defense is ready there yeah you're right
about that and the offense left go I
would argue the offenses like they need
more meat and potatoes in their past
game there are a little too much game
planning where it's I think that's why
you see that early first half success oh
I got all these new plays I drew up we
call them all up and now we get to the
second half and we've already used them
all and now our base offense needs to
have some execution to make things
happen they'd be another team I'd look
at and go now they need some of just
like some they need some normal system
plays that New England has or the Rams
have that are just like hey its first in
ten we can drop back here and find a
five or a six yard completion like the
Saints some of those teams it can't
always be created formation with a
creative motion and now we've screwed
the defense over they don't know what
we're about to hit them with and it's a
30 yard gain you know against the good
defenses and the teams that finally get
a feel for them that's gonna slow down
and they're gonna have to be able to
execute a little bit more the lines of
like what we're used to when the Vikings
are down 14 nothing can you feel
everyone on the internet [ __ ] on
Kirk Cousins your thoughts my thoughts
are I mean just ridiculousness hey
there's no way to defend the
interception pick-six that was stupid
that was a stupid decision okay and it
was a bad throw on top of that it was a
double whammy a triple whammy he should
have never thought there's four guys
there but what people aren't gonna know
is the first interception interception
and we'll hear about it today
was not his fault I don't think it was
his fault you think you were supposed to
be an outing up by Rudolph he was
supposed to run up the middle right he
read it as a single safety defense and
that safety went over the top to play
some sort of - shell defense where he
should have continued up the field I
think that's why Kirk Cousins threw the
ball we'll see Stefon Diggs admitted
when he was wrong in the pick-6 against
the Saints in few weeks on the Monday
press conference we'll see if Kyle
Rudolph does today I think there's a
good chance of that it's he's gonna have
to like deal with this scapegoat issue
he's got because he's the high one of
the highest-paid quarterbacks in the
sport and he hasn't won a playoff game
yet and until he wins some playoff game
he's not great against teams with over
500 bucks every time is oh and that's
yeah I mean that's the other one no
one's talking about how his offensive
line stinks
I mean offensive lines been banged up no
run game at all and it's not as a
creative offense as last year under
Shermer and then the other one that like
totally gets me I mean I've read this
this morning Oh
his record in prime time games this is
total Phil Simms stuff but I just laugh
when I see that crap
he's record in 12 primetime games is not
good I mean so what's a primetime game I
don't know
so the primetime games only the night
game and I'm BC there's not what they're
saying or at a Monday night game though
the only prime time games you mean the
big 425 game which gets better ratings
every person's is four and twelve and
career prime Oh prime time games cuz
none of those cowboys games at 4:25
where more people were watching those
games than any other game of the week
that doesn't count as prime time that's
just a stupid stat well they got the
Packers in primetime Sunday Night
Football week 12 yeah and two weeks
later they got Seattle Monday Night
Football
primetime will he like walks out and
goes oh no it's night time you know what
that means
it's primetime I'm gonna choke it's dark
out oh no I'm not good under the lights
except the lights are shining even on
the one o'clock games in the 425 games
and I still did good in those I need
that crap so second everybody don't
believe it what no I don't believe it I
believe I don't yeah it was not a great
game by him last night but that's a
great defense they played and they were
out banned in a tough environment
Broncos Chargers Broncos Chargers
Phillip Lindsey's incredible yeah he
Philip Rivers is a great player but also
a huge liability every week yeah I made
a mistake certainly that was that mean
without a few mistake that was the
biggest play of Sunday though was the on
third down throwing in the dirt
no the Von Miller interception we're up
double digit I mean that game was they
were indicators over they were a 19-7 in
field goal position and the Broncos
could not stop anything no I mean throws
a screen intercepted by Von Miller taken
back to inside the red zone
Denver's offense couldn't do anything
all day replays 18 yards they score a
touchdown that was a Lindsey Royce
Freeman Royce Freeman right then they
get the ball back after that it's 1914
the Chargers have a third and two
he throws a slant route to Mike Williams
to the left it goes right through Mike
Williams hands Denver gets the ball back
they go down and score again now this is
19 30 plus yards yep yeah and you're
just laying at the end or you talk about
the floor they put him up 22 19 yeah
okay man yeah that was a total
GameChanger he doesn't mean six yard
drive by Case Keenum yeah that's my
other thing with the Chargers no go into
the other play first after that what
setup the 80s are the the 76 yard drive
at the end of the game to win the game
winning field wall when Phillip Rivers
threw the dirt
yeah I mean we just we got to talk about
I think nobody's talking about that
today there was two minutes left and you
could have just run it when Denver had
no timeouts left no time taking it down
like one twice I have no problem with
the screen pass being called that's what
they called and if you know a lot of
those times you catch a team in the
right defense
it's a completion and then you know you
get a block and you go oh my gosh we
converted this third down that's
unbelievable we win the game but Denver
was ready for it and the fact that
Phillip Rivers threw the ball at the
feet of the receiver to stop the clock
well the Broncos needed the extra 40
seconds and that's what saved them at
the end of the day I know can't believe
the Chargers lose that game yeah that's
one of the thing I was
we're thinking about is you you said
this before that the Saints have a poker
in their ass and it's called the Rams
where every week they play they go gotta
keep pace with the Rams kind of keep
pace with the Rams how much does the
Chargers loss in a weird way impact the
psyche of the Chiefs yeah we're the
Chargers were gone were seven and two
year nine and one right behind you I a
loss like this to the Broncos a division
on division crime yeah they can feel
easier yeah they're gonna rest easier
yeah that kind of kills me for Monday
yeah it's uh I mean normal human letdown
the thing they have in their favor is
number two is Pittsburgh and they beat
Pittsburgh had dead so they really
basically have a one and a half game
lead there I still think there's enough
of a poker though and the fact that the
Steelers are still close and the
Patriots are not looming far behind who
did beat us head to head so III don't
think you should panic about tonight
not yet I don't think it's weird
although yeah I mean overall I don't I
don't think they're at that stage quite
yet where they can go okay we're good we
can rest easy here you know it's a
little different in with the the Saints
and Rams where you know they're clearly
the two best teams in the NFC and we
know the Saints want to have home-field
advantage yeah and as long as the Rams
keep winning they're gonna have to keep
staying on their eggs I also have
mahomes my fantasy teams so I don't want
them to loosen up at all
but this week they play the Rams next
week the Chiefs go to Oakland the week
after that they host the Ravens that's
week 14 right week 15 they play the
Chargers so that's huge
yes week 16 is at Seattle and then week
17 they play the Raiders again not easy
not easy
hold on mice there we go it's waiting
for my internet what does this do for
the Chargers losing a game like that
honestly for the Chargers in this kind
of scenario is there could be a lot of
good taken out of this type of situation
just a refocus you know do we know what
happened with Corey luging as far as
what the prognosis I think he's out for
the year
damn he's definitely out for the year
yeah they get Bosa back and Bosa was
playing great he will be certainly a
thing but having both of them would have
been amazing yeah well having you know
they're not the deepest team in the in
the world as far as the defense at
tackle position anyways but you know the
charger is still the quality football
team playoff caliber football team you
talk about their stretch they'll let go
I mean that's you started you already
say it no but they got Arizona then at
Pittsburgh home against the Bengals at
the chief home against the Ravens at the
Bronco yeah I will not be easy
man none of them except for the
Cardinals game maybe yeah one of the
Sunday morning dumps in addition to the
Jalen Ramsey one by Adam Schefter
was that the Browns were interested in
interviewing Condoleezza Rice and I'm
just curious what you were thinking when
you saw that because the the sports
world exploded and I'm seeing people
saying today that it was an insult to
the coaching profession for this to even
be a thing it is a great respect for
Condoleezza Rice and the things she's
done but I just it actually just speaks
to the overall theme again of like just
respecting anybody that's ever studied
the sport or done anything at all you
know it's I don't get it I mean I don't
understand why she was on the final four
playoff committee for the NCAA college
football either I don't get we got
astronauts on there her around there
let's not get people that actually know
about football
let's just get some people who were
really great at other things and watch
football occasionally and they'll
determine everybody else's life in
college football
just stupid crap there was yeah I don't
know if there is this year yeah it's
just there's so many stupid things like
that but I don't know it's how was that
quote presented I don't even understand
that quote I don't read stupid crap like
that
you mean the tweet by shefter yeah the
tweet what was the quote by John Dorsey
as far as him he just said he thought
about it right I mean he didn't say like
I'm gonna interview her but what was the
quote and I gotta find the John Dorsey
one do you want more or the shefter
original night rather the John Dorsey
one I mean that's where he's going from
right
Brown's response former Secretary of
State Condoleezza Rice is a great leader
possesses the highest possible character
and also happens to be a Browns fan I
have the utmost respect and admiration
for all she's accomplished and was
honored to meet her for the first time
earlier this season our coaching search
will be thorough and deliberate but we
are still in the process of composing
the list of candidates and Secretary
Rice has not been discussed I think she
was trying to be very respectful yeah
but the fact that he even got mentioned
to me was the who of the day - oh that's
where I'd just I'm sick of that crap man
I don't know what else to say I mean
we're all gonna waste our time and
energy like we really think that's a
possibility somebody says it in passing
and somebody tweets it out we go oh my
gosh the problems are the dumpster fire
I thought they were oh my gosh they're
gonna sign somebody that's never coached
football before I never played football
before
I'm all for women coaching too just so
we got that straight all for it
yeah and yeah in the sport already there
I think it's it's insulting to those
women for Condoleezza Rice yeah exactly
right
Pano's lions mmm Kenney gala day is a
number-one receiver and I don't
understand going for two there at the
end I don't know if it's just Graham
Cano having missed a kick in a field
goal and of course it is you do know
that sad don't act like you don't know I
mean he missed a chip shot field goal in
the extra point so of course they'll go
to Graham you know you still would have
got again I probably would have to I
probably I'm not gonna lie but I'm not
gonna lie where I would have gone cam
run all right I know but the guy was
wide freakin open and he just missed it
as missed it yeah there's nothing else
to say he missed it and Devin Funchess
some of his drops during the game
Carolina did not play their best game
but man they had chances to kind of make
things interesting to win the football
game outright and yeah they did not play
well I know DJ Moore was fantastic that
was fun to watch he's he's certainly a
special player but I'm not mad at Ron
Rivera for that decision as compared to
you know Mike Vrabel in London or like
we talked about
Frank Reich against the Houston Texans
and overtime at least there was
something that warranted this decision
it wasn't just like we're trying to be
aggressive I think he was going damn my
kicker just like shankha Potamus the
last two kicks and I don't trust him
right now and I'm just gonna go with Cam
Newton making a play here to win the
football game because they probably have
it will at the end yeah it was there to
be had and you know he just missed the
throw
Carolina is now five and Oh at home one
and four away from home yeah
they lose to Detroit started off slow in
that game got destroyed by the Steelers
on the road started off down 17 nothing
to the Eagles won that game started off
17 nothing to Washington lost that game
there started out seven down 17 nothing
that's why and then Atlanta they were
down like twenty four to seven something
like that right and they lost that game
31 to 24 so Carolina's not a great road
team down the stretch home against
Seattle at the bucks at the Browns home
against the Saints home against the
Falcons at the Saints yeah not easy not
easy they match up well with Seattle I
think they should be able to beat the
bucks but the Bucks offense is always
scary and they should be able to beat
the Browns but you know then those last
three that's that's not gonna be easy at
all yeah they're certainly I I have lost
all of my confidence in them yeah I've
lost a lot I definitely am NOT as hot I
mean I I've I can say that I feel like I
was wrong as strong as I felt about them
a few weeks back certainly I mean the
Steelers game was disappointing
yesterday that's a game I'm really again
there were so many close games at one
o'clock I feel like at a Monday I have a
better feel for games as a whole where
like this is one of the games where I
was like man I really need to go back
and watch a few situations on film and
see how it beared out because I can't
even quite get my true honest take to
what I think happened I just need to see
it like to me it was I was shocked that
the Detroit Lions offense moved the ball
so easily on the Carolina Panthers I saw
the Devin Funchess passes I saw a few
plays where cam I thought should have
hit some open receivers
the end of the football game that
situation but other than that I don't
know if I can sit here and say that I
feel overly confident about anything
else in the game talking about it like
intelligently other than the DJ more is
phenomenal and is officially the go-to
guy for the Panthers is it time to
officially pass the torch from Joe
Flacco to Lamar Jackson I do think so
I've yeah I 27 carries over a hundred
rushing yards for Lamar jacks and it was
an offense that I had never really seen
before yeah tons of motion tons of
movement Marty morning wake bringing a
lot of those mike vick play calls from
back in the day for lamar jackson right
is it sustainable and is it time well it
if there's a time to do it it's now
sustainable you know yes it's
sustainable I don't think he can run the
ball 27 times a game it needs to be
somewhere between 12 and 20 but what we
did see out of those 27 runs yesterday
is I can only remember one like squared
up good hit he took he's pretty good at
you know just sliding off the edge of a
guy to where they can't hit him square I
do like that I do think he looks faster
than he's looked all year I mean I think
he was faster than he was all year he
was warm he got a chance to you know get
into the flow of the game he got to
practice all week except for like you
said earlier the day where he was in the
hospital yep so incredible he's maybe
gotten too shaped that way and I think
as the game goes on yeah he's playing
quarterback and doesn't wear down quite
as what quite the way the rest of the
defenders do and he did he looked fast
as hell but I do think he fits what they
want to do as a team in general I think
that's the big thing I would look at in
what way run the ball control the clock
let their defense dominate that's kind
of what they did yesterday I mean you
know they were under the position the
power they're kind of driving he threw a
dumb interception ok he's your rookie
they get the ball again they're getting
close to midfield
it's fourth and one they quarterback
sneak it they don't get it and now the
Bengals go down and score there so
that's where changed the game but then
they answered right back I think he was
more impressive in the past game that I
expect him to be I really like his
different arm angles and the things he
throws at it but my big point would be
with this left go I don't know how you
feel about this but
like what's the difference what's what's
the difference like what I mean I I know
like everybody thinks like oh go back to
Joe Flacco why why cuz he won the Super
Bowl six seven years ago
look I've been saying for three hours
that watching Joe Flacco and the Ravens
offense is the most painful loss yeah
they are the opposite of watching the
Colts it's it's like praying that a wide
receiver that you know can't break
tackles breaks one because he's not
gonna take a shot yeah no I know
so you're gonna say from now on Lamar's
team I I would and I think if there's a
time to do it with the Raiders the
Falcons the Chiefs the Bucs
the Chargers the Browns I mean man they
have a favorable Wow schedule at least
for their offense as far as their
offense being able to dominate some
really bad defenses down the stretch you
know again maybe they don't have the
guts to do it they at least have to have
a legit first person yes
yeah and it's a very unceremoniously Co
but you think it's time you think that
Lamar Jackson is capable I thought that
he was very impressive I thought that he
was a lot faster than I thought he was
gonna be he made some throws running out
that were incredible he was of able to
avoid the pass rush and then reset and
and keep looking downfield the one
interception was really bad I think he's
not seeing levels yet like he'll look at
the secondary and not see a line back he
had two guys in the flat open he just
was getting too rambunctious and
confident but yeah I mean he's a rookie
he's gonna make some mistakes like that
what about but I mean the running game
you know opened up all of a sudden
there's running lanes for these guys
well and they played a running back that
was capable of getting more that's on
the stat sheet who is that guy
Gus Edwards who's that I mean Rutgers
guy I I can't say that I know anything
in depth about him I remember what we
talked about
Rutgers running backs but I mean it
shows you what I've been telling you
about Alex Collins is it's just well
Collins is good for a 1st quarter
touchdown every week that makes you
thought he played well in the game he's
a good 2 or 3 running back you don't
want him to be your workhorse I like the
combination of Lamar and Edward
Edwards kind of the power guy then I'll
send you have the slasher and Lamar
Jackson
they got all you can against tomorrow
well you did the thing that people are
missing but you could play man-to-man
but you better have extra guys or route
or somebody's idol to sigh but defenses
will get very simple when Lamar
Jackson's that quarterback just like
sometimes they do when Russell Wilson
was in his prime with the read option or
Cam Newton because you you can't do
anything exotic cuz you're worried about
Wu if he breaks contain there's gonna be
nobody there if he scrambles or if they
run a quarterback design and run to the
right and I try to bring you know weak
linebacker a weak safety bliss blitz off
the left oh man we're gonna be
outnumbered and we blitzed it and now
he's gonna be gone to the second level
with a full head of steam so that's
gonna scare defenses into being very
simple when they play the Ravens offense
in general I am praying for the Niners
to get the first pick in the NFL Draft
yeah why pray right now they have their
they're tied with Oakland and Arizona at
two and eight why pick is an entire
offseason of breaking down what Kyle
Shanahan needs with the first pick is so
perfect for this show yeah are you
kidding me and he doesn't need a
quarterback so we can go for anybody
getting they can't draft Nick Bosa they
already have drafted a defensive line in
the last four years but I just think
that sounds like deal I'm gonna be the
only ones worthy of going in the first
pick really yeah I mean unless it's the
quarterback from Oregon I have a theory
about Andrew Luck my theory have you
ever seen the sixth sense yeah where
Bruce Willis didn't realize that he was
dead right until the end of the movie
right my theory is that Andrew Luck
played all of these years where he got
destroyed and he had pretty good weapons
on the outside but no offensive line and
now I think that Andrew Luck actually
died and now he's in football offensive
line heaven and he doesn't realize it
yet that it took him dying on the field
and a year away from the game to be
reborn into an offense that has one of
the best offensive line
I think that occasionally he comes into
the locker room and quit Nelson looks at
him and goes Andrew I see dead people
and Andrew is like kids today they're so
crazy I think Andrew Luck died and he's
in football heaven and it's behind
Braden Smith quitting Nelson Costanzo
Ryan Kelly and gluon ski it's pretty
awesome he's in heaven
yes he just doesn't know it yeah I mean
five games in a row no sack that's
unbelievable not not even hit and it's
not like get the ball out of our hands
quick type of throwing team no he's back
there galloping around I know the
culture my I've been saying this the
whole season pretty much they are my NFL
red extreme team they are the most fun
to watch again like who are the wide
receivers he's throwing - yeah I mean T
Y special but I got you yeah but yeah
that it's it's it's nothing
groundbreaking agreed first thing is as
I hope everybody's realizing how awesome
is your luck is because I feel like
everybody before the year forgot like
what kind of quarterback he is and here
he is you know second in the NFL and
touchdown passes with 29 touchdown
passes through ten weeks which is
phenomenal but I just you can't say
enough about that old line and what
they're doing I mean it truly is amazing
every time I looked at that game
yesterday and trying to keep track of
all the one o'clock games he was sitting
back there with nobody around him
throwing laser just picking them apart
29 touchdowns nine interceptions 101
quarterback rating 2,700 passing yards
and he's only been sacked ten times this
season the motile role of a role
reversal
it's vice versa Tom Brady's been SEC 16
Derek Carr has been sacked 32 DeSean
Watson's been sacked 33 times yeah
but Andrew Luck sitting there sacked 10
and it makes me ask you a very
interesting question you have two kids
if I said right now Sims Charlotte
Phillip who's your favorite kid what
would you tell me I'm not selling you
anything you'd say it's too hard I love
them both
right I don't want to do this to him
right I'm making a pic between your
football kids yeah Offensive Rookie of
the Year Quinton Nelson or say Quan
Barclay forget Phillip Lindsey forget
all these offensive players that Calvin
Ridley's we know that it's sake won but
it could be quitting Nelson quitting
Nelson or say Kwan Barkley choose your
Offensive Rookie of the Year thus far
this is the conversation that no one's
having and it's the real conference it
is the real conversation you're right
they're the two most offensively
impressive guys Baker Mayfield yeah I
had a good really good yeah you're a
third love you if you want a lot of
Offensive Rookie of the weeks tends to
be a little bit biased to the
quarterback position yes
but quit nelson say qualms Barkley I'd
probably still go sake 1 Wow but man
this is one of the best rookie years for
any offensive lineman that I've ever
seen I mean I thought I didn't think you
could be really pass up what Zack Martin
did as a rookie a few years ago I mean I
just remember turn and film on him and
going oh my gosh it's the third game of
the year and he's the best offensive
lineman in football this is unreal and
quite Nelson is right there in that
discussion except he's gotten like the
media attention to go along with it
that's different like and it's more
truly about him you know where I feel
like Zack Martin got you know the low
line and generally he's this awesome guy
that's with this awesome line and watch
out like Quentin is truly getting
individual offense alignment at
attention which is so weird I think yeah
I think we have helped the fact that
he's came from Notre Dame all of that
but either way you're still gonna go
sake one man sake wanna clone was pretty
a most gifted people I've ever seen
that some were asking I know well I'm
still his stats are still really awesome
- I don't know what else to say Quintin
Nelson is one of the most gifted oh my
god right now is averaging 4.6 yard to
carry seven touchdowns 728 rushing yards
and when you go over to receiving I know
if he's gonna pop up right away
say qualm Barkley 540 receiving yards
three touchdowns
so 540 and seven something so he's in
like the 1300s for total yards yeah
versus Quintin Nelson which has been
keeping Andrew Luck clean for five weeks
yes it's part of the great wall of Indy
yeah I I would go with Barkley but
that's really close I guess it's
probably the running back sexy factor
remember how we were talking about the
Dawson which is more touchdowns than
incompletions a quarterback did it
yesterday
Eli Manning right 17 of 18 two
touchdowns a hundred and fifty five
point eight the Giants are back if only
he could play the PIPA Bay Buccaneers
every week or the 49ers yeah I mean but
look this is exactly what we said was
gonna happen with a giant yeah they
start the year they have that murderers
row of Defense's not necessarily
murderers row of teams but the defenses
were crazy first week Jack's worse now
everyone's finally appreciating how good
the Cowboys were in week two there
Houston Texans JJ Watt merciless we know
how good they are the New Orleans Saints
a super attacking defensive front
when Marcus Davenport was still healthy
at the Panthers home against the Eagles
at the Falcons now it's starting to get
a little bit easier
the Niners the Bucs the Eagles are a lot
easier than they were last week yeah
back of the Bears yeah Washington Titans
yeah it'll be a little interesting yeah
it's gonna be I mean they're certainly
improving their old line has definitely
been better
Eli's been better there's no doubt about
they're doing a good job of the Giants
beat the Eagles Oh it'll be tight yeah
that that's a very embarrassing football
team the thing I think people are
missing too is the Giants defense is
what's really disappointing to me I mean
the Buccaneers marched up and down the
field on the Giants yesterday you know
the 49ers had the same luxury the week
before I'm just I'm amazed at how bad
the Giants D has played really
throughout the year letting out so many
big plays Eli Manning his pack they'll
bring him back next year
maybe you will did you see car and Groot
and yelling on the sidelines I did what
was youth what were you thinking I mean
that's that's that's status quo for
Johnny G I mean
you know how many times can I tell you
if I had a dollar for every time I came
over to the sidelines and he was looking
at me like I mean what the [ __ ] he
thinking why didn't you throw the middle
poster bah bah bah I mean he
micromanages and the thing is is it's
healthy
it's fine you can talk back to him - he
doesn't like think he's like on a
pedestal like evil dictator like how
dare I talk a--the back to me the head
coach no you can say hey [ __ ] you John
he wasn't open or I had a guy on my back
or whatever and he might look at you
like how dare you say that but he gets
over it in a hurry it's honestly I think
he's gonna be happy in the long run the
way Derek Carr Derek Hart show life for
the first time yesterday cursed him out
a few times I mean we don't know if he
cursed a few times I think he was also
just kind of like saying things and
showing some like well there was which
we got a block or gosh this guy you know
whatever I mean the Cardinals should be
embarrassed that they let Oakland even
in that game Arizona got a goal-line
stand there were so many moments in this
game that should have gone bad and it
should have covered the five point
spread I swear I'm not that upset about
it but like won the the Raiders goal
line stand Arizona or dunno yeah and
then Derek Carr throws it to the Arizona
linebacker who drops a return for a
touchdown
then David Johnson has like a 60 yard
touchdown run call back from a hold but
there was one time where the receiver
was supposed to go on and out and up and
he didn't and you saw Derek Carr go come
on run out now yeah right what the hell
yeah and I was like whoa angry right so
Jon Gruden is gonna bring out angry
Derek Carr if Derek Carr wants to last
there he better yeah cuz Jon he does not
you know like the old saying like he
does not want like a a cruise-ship
coordinator he wants a battleship
commander and he wants somebody that's
gonna be able to be extension of himself
in the coaching staff that can yell at
the old line and things like I was just
getting to that in my time and then I
got hurt so you're telling me if I'm
watching the Raiders yeah the worst
thing I could see is car come off the
field and Gruden says something and
keeps walking the best thing that I can
see even though it looks the most
confrontational is direct car stopping
and arguing with Jon Gruden well that's
actually the healthiest relationship
route another thing that has to happen
on every series I mean if that's
happening every series they walk off the
field and then divert there's a problem
if they're doing but for three to four
spats like that a game yes that's that's
so in your mind it's actually better
than it's happened it is it definitely
is yes how Gruden communicate it is a
little bit how he communicates
especially on Sundays he's not logical
on Sundays always he's not capable of
having logical discussions he's caught
up in the moment and he wants to yell at
you just because he wants a yell cuz he
didn't get the first down and he's just
gonna yell at you cuz he knows I have
the best relationship with this guy and
I can yell at him and hopefully
everybody else will hear me too he yells
at you yeah was there anybody that would
come up to you and be like man you know
how he is
yeah definitely I mean it could be if
you have certain guys well I mean it
could have been Joey Galloway who came
up to me and I came in you know shake
that off shake that [ __ ] off man don't
worry I mean whatever or it could be
even his assistant at the time Paul
Kelly okay Paul Kelly haven't heard of
this game yeah Paul Kelly PK is with the
Washington Redskins under Jay now but he
would be another guy that would always
come up to me and be like hey hey if
he's yelling at you means he likes you a
lot that's what I'm saying
right so that's part of we're looking at
it and going man the Raiders are a mess
but really ergo that this is actually
good yeah this is not a bad thing at all
I don't look at it this is the type of
coaching staff and relationship he has
with a quarterback I will say this yes I
am happy that this Raiders experience
has brought in Jared cooked to life this
is the Jarret cook we've been waiting
for for about like five six years cookie
but he went to Green Bay and we went
he's gonna explode with Aaron Rodgers oh
but in Oakland yeah every time I look up
he's stiff-arming somebody into the
third crust of the earth Gurdon is
pretty good at using the tight end and
you know they've made him a focal point
to work the middle to field cooks a
special athlete he's a big guy he was
awesome man when I played with him at
Tennessee
you know his cook his biggest thing was
yeah I was with the Cookie Monster you
know he would always pop it
practice he just had to get used to
football on the movements and you know
why was he not always just a little
stiff at times I remember always Jeff
Fischer like when he would make awkward
adjustments to the ball like Fischer
being man we could just like get him out
in the basketball court and learn him
how to like how to play with his back to
the basket and post people up that way
and like he was right it was kind of
what he needed to get a feel for but man
big strong and phenomenal speed all
right I got a fan question for your Sims
we're gonna wrap up what are you
giggling about vendrick over here this
is from caddie Romina yeah I'm a Packers
fan and although I do like McCarthy as a
head coach I get jealous when I see
Shaun McVeigh call in place for the
ramps if you were building your team and
you to choose between an Aaron Rodgers
talent or a Shaun McVeigh level coach
who would you choose
gosh that's so hard I mean whoo well I
mean there's so many other things I want
to ask off this okay so we get Shaun
McVeigh well quarterback am i getting I
mean I'm getting Blake bortles I don't
give a damn whose offense you got if you
got Blake bortles it's an order play
this right if you get Aaron Rodgers yeah
you get an average head coach okay if
you get Sean McVeigh you get an average
quarterback I would probably take Sean
McVeigh so you would take Sean McVeigh
and Colt McCoy over Aaron Rodgers and
[Music]
Mike McCarthy yeah yeah I think it
offensive genius can do more with less
than the quarterback oh it's Sean
Payton's don't write briefs trying to do
you're such a chair just kidding shut up
yeah I just think they could do more
with less wear you know hey you have the
quarterback that it's tough to make
magic happen on a weekly basis when
there's no schematic advantage
whatsoever for your offense I mean none
I actually had someone in the Instagram
and I forget who it was so I apologize
but someone asked this would you rather
have Aaron Rodgers or a defensive line
of Aaron Donald JJ Watt like the best if
like all four defensive line
positions are amazing or Aaron Rodgers
what would you rather have and you're
doing the same thing you'll say I say
average D Lyman and the average D line
and Aaron Rodgers or an average
quarterback and four studs on the D line
ooh I'd probably take Aaron Rodgers
they're interesting is there's way I
think you can skate by getting by yeah
three step drop screens speed sweeps
there's other ways you can schematically
take away the D line out of the game at
times so I know that's a tough one I
like thanks guys that's what my answer
was dead these are fun I think the one
thing we need to figure out though is
who is the average quarterback that we
will use going forward right like yeah
who is this whose QB 16 I mean are we
gonna say QB 16 right here I have
started already - whose QB 16 oh no
we're [ __ ]
let's go with 1707 - Tom Brady
what this is according to what its
quarterback ratings right aren't they a
stupid stat or stupid we're gonna sign
off but I want to hear this whose gave
me the top five flu bag that's why
quarterback ratings are stupid give me
that give me the top everything is about
completion percentage Oh so number one
is Drew Brees right number two is who
the obvious one Pat Mahone right number
three is an obvious one tonight Oh Jared
go Jared Goff number four is also in LA
Phillip Rivers right number five is in
Atlanta Matt Ryan number six is Russell
Wilson okay number seven scam Newton
number eight Aaron Rodgers number 9's
luck
number ten is the almighty Ryan
Fitzpatrick stop yeah you're telling me
that if you just went by quarterback
rating right Ryan Fitzpatrick is seven
spots ahead of Tom Brady but why is he
only one spot behind Andrew Luck and
Aaron Rodgers the real question well
it's likely this way Ryan Fitzpatrick
has thrown 17 touchdowns and 12
interceptions
but that only justifies him being two
points behind somebody who threw 19
touchdowns and one interception
the quarterback rating is stupid stupid
we need to create a sim scale we do
there has to be some way again
completion percentage is a stupid stat
it's taken way too highly
that's all a great lecturer breeze right
I mean it's a reason Carson Wentz is
probably you know is up there he's
thrown for 77% I mean that's that's all
I hear with him to like great okay you
know a complete true percentage is great
but tell me how are these completions
coming about I mean if you're throwing
screen passes or 4-yard child crosses
all game Wow whoopty-doo you're leaving
the leaning and completion percentages
please be 50 he is 26 down in Alex Smith
Joe Flacco Case Keenum land Wow
yes amazing yeah alright we're gonna get
out of here I need to go catch a flight
I gotta go to Las Vegas
so again who's gonna win tag or fill
tiger or fill well we're gonna be
talking on Wednesday we're gonna do one
more podcast that's gonna come out
Thursday
do you want to know why save save it for
Wednesday okay save it for the podcast
as it might surprise it's not gonna
surprise me I know you're picking you
have no idea I'd lean to well it's one
of two options Oh
forceps he's out on me Bendrick would
say did we hit it all today I don't even
know did me and the lef koe man says man
I have no idea I don't know either
alright see ya
you